we just got our first look at the 8th
main line Resident Evil game and Wow
[Applause]
the trailer was absolutely incredible
and has us hyped up but we have even
more details about the game story and
gameplay thanks to a PlayStation blog
post and a special video message from
the developers so let's break down
everything we know so far about the game
plus a few of our own theories first up
you probably want to know exactly how
you're supposed to say the game's title
it's not Resident Evil 8 village or 8th
age Resident Evil it's simply called
Resident Evil village with the Roman
numeral in the logo as a nod to the fact
that it is the 8th main line Resident
Evil title I get the feeling a lot of us
are still going to be referring to it as
re 8 though now thanks to PlayStation
Blog we have details about the game
setup village takes place a few years
after the events of Resident Evil 7 with
returning protagonist Ethan winters and
his wife Mia having settled down after
the madness that took place in the Baker
Mansion by the way this does confirm
that me a living is the cannon ending of
re 7 which we all figured would be the
case but now we know for sure things
take a turn for even when Chris Redfield
who appeared at the end of re 7 and
starred in it's not a hero DLC shows
back up in Ethan's life causing what
Capcom calls some shocking actions
this leaves Ethan to seek out answers
answers that lie in the game's titular
village considering Mia isn't mentioned
as going to the village with Ethan it's
possible these shocking actions could be
Mia's death at the hands of Chris with
Chris filling the role of the villain
this time around the scene at the end of
the trailer does seem to suggest as much
further evidence of Chris's darker role
is hinted at in this key art of the game
showing a brooding snow-covered Chris
with dried blood on his face
considering that Chris has long been the
series pure hearted good guy this could
easily be a misdirection where you're
just supposed to think Chris is the bad
guy but on the other hand a lot of
horrific stuff has happened to Chris
over the years and that does change a
person
we don't know if he's still involved
with blue umbrella the organization he
was working with in rt7
and if they have a role to play in all
this the developers considered the
titular village to be a key character in
itself think of the level of character
in detail that re sevens Baker Mansion
had but now it's an entire village it's
safe to say we are getting strong re4
vibes with the ramshackle village
sitting below a massive castle the
developer message video gives us a brief
look at some gameplay of an entrance
hall interior perhaps from the castle
and it reminds us a lot of Spencer
mansion we don't want to get too ahead
of ourselves but this game seems to be
ticking all the right boxes in terms of
setting now let's talk about some
gameplay village Bill's off the design
of Resident Evil 7 retaining that game's
first-person perspective the developers
have stated that village will be quote
upping the ante a bit on action when
compared to re 7 but the game is still
very much considered a survival horror
experience it will also have more
exploration than re 7 did which fits
with the upgrade from a Louisiana
plantation to an entire village the game
runs on an updated version of the re
engine meant to take advantage of
next-gen hardware and will feature no
load times village was revealed during
Sony's PS 5 event but it has also been
confirmed for Xbox series X and PC
perhaps one of the most exciting reveals
is a brief look we have at the games
inventory menu the clean design
aesthetic is very much in line with re 7
and the recently released remakes
however this time the items are all
carried in a briefcase that uses the re
for Tetris inventory system we also see
100 Lai up in the corner which might be
a currency system I'm not trying to get
my hopes up too much for the return of
the merchants but considering all the re
for parallels it's hard not to get
excited at the possibility and finally
the developers teased this piece of key
are saying that they debated even
showing it because of how much is
revealed in the image this thing also
shows up in the trailer in the village
itself which makes it likely that it's
an idol or symbol of some sort we're
getting some strong las Plagas vibes
from the dried up husk in the middle but
it's hard to say for sure it's time to
put on your detective capps internets
and get to sleuthin
that was a lot of info thrown at us but
there's still a ton we don't know like
what's up with that werewolf guy
we're promised even more reveals for
village towards the end of the summer so
make sure to stay tuned to games for all
things at resident evil
[Music]